Does your anger burn fiery red? When you're sad, do you say that you're feeling blue? Have you ever felt green with envy or purple with rage? English speakers are familiar with these color metaphors, all of which rely on linking color with emotion. But where do those links come from? Are they universal, or do different cultures have different color emotion associations? And can colors actually make you feel calm or sad?
你的愤怒会像火一样燃烧吗？当你悲伤时，你会说自己感到忧郁（feeling blue）吗？你是否曾感到嫉妒得发绿（green with envy）或愤怒得发紫（purple with rage）？英语使用者对这些颜色隐喻都很熟悉，它们都依赖于将颜色与情感联系起来。但这些联系从何而来？它们是普遍存在的，还是不同的文化对颜色与情感有不同的联想？颜色真的能让你感到平静或悲伤吗？
or angry? Will painting the walls of your house blue help you feel calmer at home? Is there a reason that so many hospitals seem to be painted a particular shade of green? And is there any relationship to the notion that green is associated with feeling sick to your stomach? Color psychologists are studying questions like these and others too. For instance, do people's favorite colors tell us anything about their personality? Are there universal favorite colors? Are there gender differences in how people experience or describe color. Why do we associate pink with girls and blue with boys? And more broadly, how does color affect human cognition and emotion? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
还是愤怒？把家里的墙壁漆成蓝色能让你在家里感到更平静吗？为什么这么多医院似乎都漆成某种特定的绿色，这有什么原因吗？这与“绿色与胃部不适有关”的说法有什么关系吗？色彩心理学家正在研究这些问题以及其他问题。例如，人们最喜欢的颜色能告诉我们关于他们性格的任何信息吗？是否存在普遍最喜欢的颜色？人们在体验或描述颜色时是否存在性别差异？为什么我们将粉色与女孩联系在一起，而将蓝色与男孩联系在一起？更广泛地说，颜色如何影响人类的认知和情感？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Domitzella Yonoskeita, a senior research fellow at the University of Vienna in Austria. She is an experimental color psychologist who studies the links between color and emotion and cognition across cultures and individuals. She's also interested in the role of color in aesthetics and art. In her work, she aims to use rigorous research to validate or debunk myths in color psychology. She has authored dozens of scientific articles and also writes a blog for the general public called color psychology. Dr. Jonas Keita, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me.
该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是奥地利维也纳大学的高级研究员多米泽拉·约诺斯凯塔（Dr. Domitzella Yonoskeita）博士。她是一位实验色彩心理学家，研究跨文化和跨个体之间颜色与情感及认知之间的联系。她还对颜色在美学和艺术中的作用感兴趣。在她的工作中，她旨在利用严谨的研究来验证或揭穿色彩心理学中的神话。她撰写了数十篇科学文章，并为公众撰写了一个名为“色彩心理学”的博客。约诺斯凯塔博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢你的邀请。
Are color associations universal? Do people around the world associate the same colors with the same emotion or does it vary by country and culture? You've done some research in this area. Tell us what you've found. So we actually wanted the same thing. Other links between colors and emotions universal. So we started the International Color Emotion Association survey currently running in 80 countries and we have it in 46 languages, which sounds like an amazing, amazingly big word. work to do. And we managed to collect data from over 15,000 participants. And now we kind of have
颜色联想是普遍的吗？世界各地的人们是否将相同的颜色与相同的情感联系在一起，还是因国家和文化而异？您在这个领域做过一些研究。告诉我们您发现了什么。我们实际上也想知道同样的事情。颜色和情感之间的联系是普遍的吗？因此，我们发起了“国际颜色情感联想调查”，目前在80个国家进行，我们有46种语言版本，这听起来是一项令人惊叹的、极其庞大的工作。我们成功收集了超过15,000名参与者的数据。现在我们算是有了
an answer to this question. And the answer is, yes, the links between colors and emotions are universal. So wherever you go in the world, you will find that people associate red with anger and love, yellow with joy, black with sadness, and so on. And of course, there are also some more culture-specific associations. For example, we know that red is a color of good luck in China. So on top of these universal associations, they also have some specific associations like associating red with joy and amusement and more positive associations. So kind of our culture is shaping the universally based color motion associations. And is that intrinsic or is it somehow learned? Because many of us just exposed to these kinds of concepts. Yes. So
这个问题的答案。答案是，是的，颜色和情感之间的联系是普遍的。所以无论你走到世界哪个角落，你都会发现人们将红色与愤怒和爱联系在一起，黄色与快乐，黑色与悲伤，等等。当然，也有一些更具文化特异性的联想。例如，我们知道红色在中国是好运的颜色。因此，除了这些普遍的联想之外，他们还有一些特定的联想，比如将红色与快乐和娱乐联系起来，以及更多的积极联想。所以，某种程度上，我们的文化正在塑造基于普遍性的颜色情感联想。这是内在的还是后天习得的？因为我们许多人只是接触到了这些概念。是的，所以
It's not an easy question to answer because to know that we would have to look at infants and they don't really have the language for colors and the language for emotions. So what we see in infant studies is that there is an immediate reaction to color red. So color red attracts attention and infants look at it longer and we can assume that they prefer this color. But does it mean that they associate with emotions we don't know? And when we go to older participants, we start seeing that these associations are emerging as children are growing up. And the older children get, the more diverse associations get, which is kind of showing that they are learning it over time through their, by being in society.
这不是一个容易回答的问题，因为要了解这一点，我们必须观察婴儿，而他们并没有真正掌握颜色和情感的语言。因此，我们在婴儿研究中看到的是，对红色有一种直接的反应。红色会吸引注意力，婴儿注视它的时间更长，我们可以假设他们更喜欢这种颜色。但这是否意味着他们将其与情感联系起来，我们不得而知。当我们观察年龄较大的参与者时，我们开始看到这些联想随着孩子的成长而出现。孩子年龄越大，联想就越多样化，这在某种程度上表明他们是通过身处社会中随着时间的推移而学习到的。
And in fact, here fits in the research I'm currently conducting on blind participants, that even if people who have never seen color in the life, so they are blind from birth, they can still associate colors with emotions in a very similar way. So again, we're talking about this universality, and we are talking about the idea that color emotion associations are learned. I mentioned in the introduction some color phrases like feeling blue when you're sad or being green with envy. Do you have any favorite color metaphors from other languages or cultures that maybe would surprise English speakers? Well, first of all, I wanted to comment on this feeling blue, because this is the metaphor that only exists in English.
事实上，这符合我目前正在对盲人参与者进行的研究，即使是那些一生中从未见过颜色的人，也就是先天失明的人，他们仍然可以以非常相似的方式将颜色与情感联系起来。所以，我们再次谈论这种普遍性，并且我们谈论的是颜色情感联想是后天习得的这一观点。我在介绍中提到了一些颜色短语，比如当你悲伤时感到忧郁（feeling blue），或者嫉妒得发绿（green with envy）。你是否有来自其他语言或文化中令英语使用者感到惊讶的颜色隐喻？嗯，首先，我想评论一下这个“感到忧郁（feeling blue）”，因为这是一个仅存在于英语中的隐喻。
So when we go to other languages, we don't find it. And we find that people think blue is a very positive color associated with calmness, contentment, relaxation, and even English speakers, in addition to associating blue with sadness, they are associating it with positive emotions. Now, talking about color metaphors in other languages, as we know, metaphors are notoriously difficult to translate. but maybe I can mention one from my native language Lithuanian where we're talking about the degrees of anger through different colors. So if you are a little bit angry, you are white, and then you get more angry than you are red. I think that's like the standard anger.
所以当我们转向其他语言时，我们找不到它。我们发现人们认为蓝色是一种非常积极的颜色，与平静、满足、放松有关，甚至英语使用者，除了将蓝色与悲伤联系起来外，他们也将它与积极的情感联系起来。现在，谈到其他语言中的颜色隐喻，正如我们所知，隐喻以难以翻译而闻名。但也许我可以提到一个来自我的母语立陶宛语的例子，我们通过不同的颜色来谈论愤怒的程度。如果你有一点生气，你是白色的，然后你变得更生气，你就变成了红色。我认为那是标准的愤怒。
And then you get furious, you get black. And if you are extremely, extremely furious, then you are purple. So languages can also code not only the emotions with colors, but also the intensity of emotion with colors. Can colors make us feel emotions? I'm wondering if you're in a red room, are you more likely to become angry or feel amorous, or do you feel calmer if you're looking at blue or green in a landscape?
然后你变得狂怒，你就变成了黑色。如果你极其、极其狂怒，那么你就是紫色的。所以语言不仅可以用颜色来编码情感，还可以用颜色来编码情感的强度。颜色能让我们感受到情感吗？我想知道如果你在一个红色的房间里，你是否更容易变得愤怒或感到多情，或者如果你在风景中看到蓝色或绿色，你会感到更平静吗？
This is a very good question. I've been working on the links between colors and emotions for 10 years, and every time we are researching them, we are just associating the color with the word of emotion. So it doesn't mean, this kind of research doesn't mean that colors make you feel anything. To answer this question, we have to put people in spaces that are colored through, let's say, VR or light or paint, and then we need to measure their felt emotions. So there are very few controlled studies in this domain, and the ones that are there,
这是一个非常好的问题。我研究颜色和情感之间的联系已经10年了，每次我们研究它们时，我们只是将颜色与情感词汇联系起来。所以这并不意味着，这种研究并不意味着颜色会让你感觉到任何东西。要回答这个问题，我们必须把人们放在通过虚拟现实（VR）、光线或油漆着色的空间里，然后我们需要测量他们感受到的情感。因此，在这个领域受控的研究非常少，而现有的那些，
they are showing very contradictory results. So in fact, it seems that colors are not affecting our emotions that much, especially they're not affecting them so specifically that if you are in a red room, you would feel anger. Yes, maybe you feel a little bit more excited. That's what one of the findings that we have. Red increases arousal, but somewhat. But the effects of colors on emotions are not so specific. So when we talk about all these links like yellow and joy or envy and green, we are really in the domain of our minds.
它们显示出非常矛盾的结果。事实上，颜色似乎并没有对我们的情感产生那么大的影响，特别是它们并没有产生如此具体的影响，以至于如果你在一个红色的房间里，你就会感到愤怒。是的，也许你会感到稍微兴奋一点。这是我们发现的结果之一。红色会增加唤醒度，但程度有限。但颜色对情感的影响并不那么具体。所以当我们谈论所有这些联系，比如黄色和快乐，或者嫉妒和绿色时，我们实际上是在我们思维的领域。
We're not really in the domain of felt emotions. So in prepping for this, I ran into some stories about the idea of drunk tank pink. And I'm hoping that you have encountered that in your work as well. This came from some research years ago that led to some prisons painting cells, a particular shade of pink, thinking that it was going to calm down the inmates. but then later they discovered this was flawed. Can you talk about that research and what's wrong with it? Yeah, so you're talking about the Baker-Miller thing.
我们并不真正处于感受到的情感领域。在准备这次访谈时，我遇到了一些关于“醉酒坦克粉（drunk tank pink）”的故事。我希望你在工作中也遇到过这种情况。这源于多年前的一些研究，导致一些监狱将牢房漆成一种特定的粉红色，认为这会使囚犯平静下来。但后来他们发现这是有缺陷的。你能谈谈那项研究以及它有什么问题吗？是的，你指的是贝克-米勒粉（Baker-Miller pink）。
Exactly. Yeah, the Beacon-Miller thing. And so the original studies were conducted in the 70s, and they showed that prisoners supposedly got karma when they were in the pink space. But in fact, they didn't really run the studies the way we are running studies nowadays. In other words, the prisoners spent one, year in the white cells and then the second year in the pink cells. So obviously when you
没错。是的，贝克-米勒粉。最初的研究是在70年代进行的，它们显示囚犯在粉红色的空间里似乎变得更平静了。但事实上，他们并没有像我们现在这样进行研究。换句话说，囚犯在白色牢房里待了一年，然后在粉红色牢房里待了第二年。所以很明显，当你
spend longer in the cells, you are less aggressive. And in 2015, Gensho and colleagues re-ran the study in using modern methods in psychological science and they found absolutely no difference between the white and the pink rooms for prisoners aggressiveness. So we can say that that no, Baker-Miller-Pink is not reducing aggressiveness in prisoners. And yet, Today, one in five prisons in Europe have at least one pink prison cell. So what does it mean? We are implementing the findings that we are not sure about much faster than the science can run behind. And therefore, it's so important to run systematic studies and really understand the phenomenon
在牢房里待的时间更长，你的攻击性就会降低。2015年，根肖（Gensho）和同事们利用心理科学的现代方法重新进行了这项研究，他们发现囚犯的攻击性在白色和粉红色房间之间绝对没有区别。所以我们可以说，不，贝克-米勒粉并不能降低囚犯的攻击性。然而，今天欧洲五分之一的监狱至少有一个粉红色的牢房。那么这意味着什么呢？我们正在实施那些我们并不确定的发现，其速度比科学研究跟进的速度要快得多。因此，进行系统的研究并真正理解这一现象是如此重要
before we are bringing them for our consumers, to policymakers. So speaking of controversial studies, you've done some work in the area of chromotherapy. which purports to show that certain colors might have healing properties. Is there any scientific evidence to support that notion? A short answer is no, not yet. So I will tell you quickly about the study we conducted. Basically, what we did in the study is we saw half of the participants saw colors, and the other half of participants saw a white sheet of paper.
在我们将其带给消费者和决策者之前。说到有争议的研究，你在色彩疗法领域做过一些工作，该疗法声称某些颜色可能具有治愈特性。有什么科学证据支持这一观点吗？简短的回答是：没有，目前还没有。所以我将快速告诉你我们进行的一项研究。基本上，我们在研究中所做的是，我们让一半的参与者看到颜色，而另一半参与者看到一张白纸。
And we measured their stress and anxiety before and after the intervention. There were also other aspects like music and guided breathing in this intervention. And we found that they are stress, anxiety were reduced after the intervention than before the intervention. So it speaks as if the intervention worked. The problem was that this reduction was exactly the same for the group which looked at colors and for the group that looked at the white sheet of paper. So it means that it's not really due to color, but probably other aspects, I mean, we know that mindfulness works, meditation works. So it just proves kind of the same thing.
我们在干预前后测量了他们的压力和焦虑。这次干预中还有其他方面，如音乐和引导呼吸。我们发现，干预后的压力和焦虑比干预前有所降低。所以这看起来好像干预起作用了。问题在于，这种降低对于看颜色的组和看白纸的组来说是完全一样的。所以这意味着这并不是真正由于颜色，而是可能由于其他方面，我的意思是，我们知道正念有效，冥想有效。所以这只是证明了同样的事情。
But when it comes to color, no, we cannot say that in this study, at least, color therapy worked. There are very few studies conducted in the area. And lastly, when we talked with participants after the experiment and we asked how they felt, some of the participants who were in the white condition, they said, oh, I wish I could have seen colors. It would have made my experience different. and those who were in the color condition said,
但当谈到颜色时，不，我们不能说至少在这项研究中，色彩疗法起作用了。该领域进行的此类研究非常少。最后，当我们在实验后与参与者交谈并询问他们的感受时，一些处于白色条件下的参与者说，哦，我希望我能看到颜色。那会让我的体验有所不同。而那些处于颜色条件下的参与者说，
oh, you know, I closed my eyes and I was just listening to the music and breathing. So also, you know, people do what they do, and there is no biological mechanism how colors, when I'm talking about light here, we're really talking about, you know, a sheet of paper with color, how colors could change physiologically, yeah, our bodies.
哦，你知道，我闭上眼睛，只是在听音乐和呼吸。所以，你知道，人们做他们所做的事，而且没有生物学机制说明颜色（我这里指的是光，我们实际上谈论的是一张有颜色的纸）如何能在生理上改变我们的身体。
So no, for now there is not much evidence, but maybe in the future. You just mentioned light, and I wanted to ask. Now, light is generally white in the sense that it contains the full spectrum of colors, and there's evidence that exposure to light can have an impact on our mental health. Is that related in any way to exposure to color? Yes and no. So you are talking now about daylight, and daylight contains kind of all the wavelengths together.
所以不，目前还没有太多证据，但也许在未来会有。你刚才提到了光，我想问一下。现在，光通常是白色的，因为它包含了全光谱的颜色，而且有证据表明接触光会对我们的心理健康产生影响。这与接触颜色有任何关系吗？是，也不是。所以你现在谈论的是日光，日光包含了各种波长。
Of course, we also have colored light. When we think about lasers, we can have any color we want. And what research shows, and it's quite strong, that exposure to intense light can improve mood, even treat seasonal affective disorder, so depression, seasonal depression. And that also goes to exposure to a specific frequencies of light, so-called in the blue range. So we could say that exposure to blue light is exciting. but that doesn't mean that exposure to a blue color is exciting. These are completely different things. We're talking at very high intensities of light,
当然，我们也有彩色光。当我们想到激光时，我们可以拥有我们想要的任何颜色。研究表明，而且证据相当有力，接触强光可以改善情绪，甚至治疗季节性情感障碍，也就是抑郁症、季节性抑郁症。这也涉及到接触特定频率的光，即所谓的蓝色范围内的光。所以我们可以说接触蓝光是令人兴奋的。但这并不意味着接触蓝色是令人兴奋的。这是完全不同的事情。我们谈论的是非常高强度的光，
which we can only achieve with a light source. And when an object, when we see a color, we usually see it reflected from an object, may be a wall or a piece of clothing, and you can never reflect light at the same intensity as the light source is producing. So often when, actually, this feeds back to our discussion about color therapy,
我们只能通过光源来实现。而当一个物体，当我们看到一种颜色时，我们通常看到的是从物体上反射出来的，可能是墙壁或一件衣服，你永远无法以光源产生的光的强度来反射光。所以通常当，实际上，这回到了我们关于色彩疗法的讨论，
Often when there are claims made about color therapy, they talk about the light, but in fact they work with colors. And these two aspects shouldn't be confused. And now here's a message from our sponsor. Are your subscriptions draining your bank account? Did you know that the average person has around 12 paid subscriptions and might not even remember signing up for half of those? And most people think they're spending around $80 a month on these subscriptions when in reality, the number is closer to $200. When you're signed up for so many things like streaming services you use to watch one show
通常当有人声称色彩疗法时，他们谈论的是光，但实际上他们使用的是颜色。这两个方面不应该混淆。现在这里有一条来自我们赞助商的消息。你的订阅是否正在耗尽你的银行账户？你知道吗，普通人大约有12个付费订阅，甚至可能不记得自己注册了一半的订阅？大多数人认为他们每月在这些订阅上花费大约80美元，而实际上，这个数字接近200美元。当你注册了这么多东西，比如你只看一个节目的流媒体服务
or free trials for delivery you don't use, it's easy to lose track of what you're paying for. And if this sounds like you, you need Rocket Money. It's an app that tracks all of your expenses so you know exactly where your money is going. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions monitors your spending and helps you lower your bills all in one place. With Rocket Money, you can easily cancel these subscriptions you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long-hold times or annoying emails with customer service. Rocket Money does that for you.
或者你根本不使用的送货服务的免费试用，很容易忘记你正在支付什么。如果这听起来像你，你需要Rocket Money。它是一个跟踪你所有支出的应用程序，所以你确切地知道你的钱花在哪里了。Rocket Money是一款个人理财应用程序，它可以发现并取消你不想要的订阅，监控你的支出，并帮助你在一个地方降低账单。使用Rocket Money，你只需按一下按钮就可以轻松取消这些你不想要的订阅。不再需要长时间的等待或与客户服务进行烦人的电子邮件往来。Rocket Money会为你做这些。
Rocket money can even negotiate to lower your bills by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. So stop wasting money on things you don't use. cancel your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash APA. That's rocketmoney.com slash APA. Rocketmoney.com slash APA. Let's talk for a minute about colorblindness, which is fairly common, especially among men, about 8% of men have some type of color blindness.
Rocket Money甚至可以协商将你的账单降低多达20%。你所要做的就是拍一张账单的照片，剩下的就交给Rocket Money处理。所以停止在你不使用的东西上浪费钱。取消你不想要的订阅，并通过访问rocketmoney.com/APA以简单的方式管理你的钱。那是rocketmoney.com/APA。Rocketmoney.com/APA。让我们花一分钟谈谈色盲，这相当普遍，特别是在男性中，大约8%的男性患有某种类型的色盲。
Do people who are colorblind make the same connections between color and emotion as everybody out? Yes, so I also conducted research on colorblindness, and in our studies we found that these men who have color vision deficiency, they did associate colors and demotions in the same way, which is very striking because they obviously do not see colors in the same way as non-colorblind participants. So what we think is happening is that they can name colors very well. Colorblindness doesn't mean that you don't see colors at all. we're talking about the red-green dichromacy. It doesn't mean that they cannot see colors at all. They only see a reduced spectrum, but through learning, through, you know, growing up in a society where we have colored pencils and colored t-shirts, they get trained how to name even very similar shades of color.
色盲的人是否像其他人一样在颜色和情感之间建立同样的联系？是的，我也对色盲进行了研究，在我们的研究中，我们发现这些患有色觉缺陷的男性，他们确实以同样的方式将颜色和情感联系起来，这非常引人注目，因为他们显然不像非色盲参与者那样看到颜色。所以我们认为发生的情况是，他们可以很好地命名颜色。色盲并不意味着你根本看不到颜色。我们谈论的是红绿色盲。这并不意味着他们根本看不到颜色。他们只是看到了一个缩小的光谱，但通过学习，通过在有彩色铅笔和彩色T恤的社会中成长，他们接受了如何命名即使是非常相似的颜色深浅的训练。
They know that this shade of green is red, and that shade of green is green. So when you confront them with the color, they can name it at 95% accuracy, and then they produce emotion associations which are similar to non-colorblind men. So this kind of finding really speaks towards the idea that color emotion associations
他们知道这种深浅的绿色是红色的，而那种深浅的绿色是绿色的。所以当你用颜色面对他们时，他们可以以95%的准确率命名它，然后他们产生的情感联想与非色盲男性相似。所以这种发现确实支持了颜色情感联想的观点
are very conceptual. They really function at the level of our mind and not, they don't have much to do with the actual perception of the color, at least nowadays. Perhaps at the beginning, you know, when they were formed, the perception mattered more, but nowadays it's really about,
是非常概念化的。它们确实是在我们思维的层面上运作，而不是，它们与颜色的实际感知没有太大关系，至少在当今是这样。也许在最初，你知道，当它们形成时，感知可能更重要，但如今这确实是关于，
it's really about just linking that too actually when we give we have some studies when we give participants a color word and they have to produce the first thing that comes to their mind and then you give the word red very often you get back anger so that's it the link is direct
这确实只是将这一点联系起来，实际上当我们进行一些研究时，我们给参与者一个颜色词，他们必须说出脑海中浮现的第一个事物，然后你给出“红色”这个词，你经常会得到“愤怒”的回应，所以就是这样，这种联系是直接的。
whereas with yellow we get sometimes joy but we also get sunshine sunlight with blue we get words like sky and ocean so here we have some objects that have probably emotional connotations. If we think sunshine, you know, if we live in the rainy countries, then probably being in a yellow sunshine makes us feel happy. So it makes sense that yellow is associated with joy. But with red, of course, there is association with blood or with, yeah,
而对于黄色，我们有时会得到“快乐”，但也会得到“阳光”、“日光”；对于蓝色，我们得到“天空”和“海洋”这样的词，所以在这里我们有一些可能具有情感内涵的物体。如果我们想到阳光，你知道，如果我们住在多雨的国家，那么身处黄色的阳光下可能会让我们感到快乐。所以黄色与快乐联系在一起是有道理的。但对于红色，当然，它与血液或与，是的，
with blood. But a link between red and anger is so immediate, it's so well established. And, you know, if there is one association that you can almost always find, it will be red and anger. Have you looked at all into the strupe phenomenon, you know, that test where maybe you have a sign or a T-shirt that says red, but the color is green, it says yellow, but it's actually orange, and people's brains are not fully connecting because they don't know exactly what it is that there's perceiving. Have you looked into that at all and what's going on in the brain when you take a strip test? Yeah, so the strip effect is very interesting. usually there is a color word, let's say, red, and it's written in a different ink, let's say blue. And what people find easier is read the color words.
与血液有关。但红色与愤怒之间的联系是如此直接，如此根深蒂固。而且，你知道，如果有一种联系你几乎总是能找到，那一定是红色和愤怒。你有没有研究过斯特鲁普效应（Stroop effect），你知道那个测试吗？也许你有一个标志或一件T恤上写着“红色”，但颜色是绿色的；它写着“黄色”，但实际上是橙色的，人们的大脑没有完全连接起来，因为他们不确定自己感知到的到底是什么。你有没有研究过那个，当你进行斯特鲁普测试时，大脑里发生了什么？是的，所以斯特鲁普效应非常有趣。通常有一个颜色词，比如“红色”，它是用不同的墨水写的，比如蓝色。人们发现更容易的是读出颜色词。
They can ignore the color of the ink, and they can just read yellow, red, green, blah, blah, blah. But what they find more difficult is to name the ink of the color because we are so trained in reading things that there is an interference between the reading and the naming of the thing we are seeing. How this links with emotions, I don't know. We've never used this test in our studies.
他们可以忽略墨水的颜色，只读出黄色、红色、绿色等等。但他们发现更困难的是说出墨水的颜色，因为我们受过太多的阅读训练，以至于在阅读和命名我们所看到的事物之间存在干扰。这与情感有何联系，我不知道。我们在研究中从未使用过这个测试。
But my prediction would be that when we ask them to link the words, probably they would have no problem associating them with emotions. But when we ask them to link the colors of the ink, there will be this interference effect. But again, I don't know if we haven't run the study. Well, let's talk for a minute about favorite colors. There are a lot of quizzes that you can take online that would have us believe that people's favorite color can tell us something about a person's personality. Is there any research that backs that up? Again, this is a very uncharted territories.
但我的预测是，当我们要求他们将这些词联系起来时，他们可能在将它们与情感联系起来方面没有问题。但当我们要求他们将墨水的颜色联系起来时，就会出现这种干扰效应。但同样，我不知道，因为我们还没有进行这项研究。好吧，让我们花点时间谈谈最喜欢的颜色。网上有很多测试会让我们相信，人们最喜欢的颜色可以告诉我们一些关于个人性格的信息。有没有什么研究支持这一点？同样，这是一个非常未知的领域。
And when we started researching color preferences, favorite colors, we were stunned. Because over and over again, wherever you look, we find that blue is the color that everyone likes. In other words, at least it's the color that no one hates. And this finding has been reported 100 years ago, and every study nowadays is still, no matter where in the world you are, blue is the favorite color. On the other hand, colors like yellow and pink are really disliked.
当我们开始研究颜色偏好、最喜欢的颜色时，我们感到震惊。因为一次又一次，无论你往哪里看，我们都发现蓝色是每个人都喜欢的颜色。换句话说，至少它是没有人讨厌的颜色。这一发现早在100年前就被报道过，而且如今的每一项研究仍然显示，无论你在世界的哪个角落，蓝色都是最喜欢的颜色。另一方面，黄色和粉色等颜色确实不受欢迎。
Now, what does it tell about our personality? We wondered the same, and we went online and we looked at different statements that are made. For example, it said that if you like red, you are an extrovert, and if you like, if you're like blue, you are a calm person. And it already made me think that, okay, they are talking about the same kind of associations that we just talked before, like blue and calmness, but now they are being translated into the personality domain. And it's never really, yeah, they're being translated into personality domain. So we set ourselves to test this. We extracted the most frequent predictions, and we collected data from 400 participants.
那么，它说明了我们的什么性格呢？我们也想到了同样的问题，我们上网查看了所做出的不同陈述。例如，它说如果你喜欢红色，你就是一个外向的人；如果你喜欢蓝色，你就是一个冷静的人。这让我想到，好吧，他们谈论的是我们刚才谈到的那种联系，比如蓝色和冷静，但现在它们被转化到了性格领域。而且它从来没有真正，是的，它们被转化到了性格领域。所以我们着手测试这一点。我们提取了最频繁的预测，并收集了400名参与者的数据。
They set their favorite color. They also completed the personality questionnaire, and we tried to correlate it too. So, well, to cut long story short, we didn't find any links between one's favorite color and one's personality, suggesting that it doesn't really matter what you like. at the same time you know you find that 50% of people are choosing blue anyway
他们设定了自己最喜欢的颜色。他们还完成了性格问卷，我们试图将两者联系起来。所以，长话短说，我们没有发现一个人最喜欢的颜色和性格之间有任何联系，这表明你喜欢什么并不重要。与此同时，你知道你发现50%的人无论如何都会选择蓝色。
so there is not so much variability in the favorite colors another thing that we find is that these predictions let's say about a red and extroversion they also apply to other colors if you like orange you're extroverted if you like yellow you're extrovert
所以最喜欢的颜色并没有太大的差异。我们发现的另一件事是，这些预测，比如关于红色和外向性的预测，它们也适用于其他颜色。如果你喜欢橙色，你是外向的；如果你喜欢黄色，你是外向的，
if you like pink you extrovert and so on and so forth so how can these associations be specific anyway so from the scientific point of view in fact, all of these claims do not make much sense. In contrast, what makes more sense is the colors that we choose to wear to signal certain things to people. So a study conducted by my colleague Chris in Rochester Institute of Technology showed that if you are looking at someone wearing red,
如果你喜欢粉色，你是外向的，以此类推。那么这些联系怎么可能是特定的呢？所以从科学的角度来看，事实上，所有这些说法都没有多大意义。相比之下，更有意义的是我们选择穿什么颜色的衣服来向人们传达某些信息。所以我的同事克里斯在罗切斯特理工学院进行的一项研究表明，如果你看着一个穿红色衣服的人，
you think they are more extroverted. So it doesn't matter whether they are actually more extroverted or not, but the choice of color is signaling certain properties, and they have meaning in our society. Are there gender differences in the way that people experience color? And I'm asking because there's a stereotype that women notice and name multitudes of subtle shades. Like they'll talk about lilac and lavender and periwinkle, well, men will just say purple or blue. Is there any science that backs that up, or is that just a stereotype that's based on gender expectations? Indeed, this is a very, I know exactly which meme you are talking about.
你会认为他们更外向。所以他们是否真的更外向并不重要，但颜色的选择是在传达某些属性，它们在我们的社会中是有意义的。人们体验颜色的方式是否存在性别差异？我这样问是因为有一个刻板印象，即女性会注意到并命名大量微妙的色调。比如她们会谈论丁香紫、薰衣草紫和长春花蓝，而男性只会说紫色或蓝色。有没有什么科学依据支持这一点，还是这仅仅是基于性别期望的刻板印象？确实，这是一个非常，我知道你指的是哪个梗。
And what I can say is that there is a high variability in the number of color terms people know. So some know only 11 basic terms and others maybe know 100, especially when we go to specialists who have to use colors in their everyday life. But when we, so there is this very high variability, but there is no difference between men and women. So some men can know a lot of colors and other women can know few colors, few color terms. So, yeah.
我能说的是，人们所知道的颜色术语数量存在很大的差异。所以有些人只知道11个基本术语，而其他人可能知道100个，特别是当我们接触到在日常生活中必须使用颜色的专家时。但是当我们，所以存在这种非常大的差异，但男性和女性之间没有区别。所以有些男性可以知道很多颜色，而其他女性可能知道很少的颜色，很少的颜色术语。所以，是的。
How did we end up associating pink with girls and blue with boys? Where did that meme come from? Yes, this is actually not a very old association. So this is about 100 years ago in 1920s. It just popped up that suddenly, society started coding, kind of gender coding the kids before they were wearing white. And there is this idea that there was a reversal in the association, that in the past, boys were associated with pink and girls with blue.
我们是如何最终将粉色与女孩、蓝色与男孩联系起来的？那个梗是从哪里来的？是的，这实际上并不是一个很古老的联系。所以这是大约100年前，在1920年代。它突然出现，社会开始对孩子进行性别编码，之前他们穿的是白色的。而且有一种观点认为，这种联系曾经发生过逆转，即在过去，男孩与粉色联系在一起，女孩与蓝色联系在一起。
So this is actually not so true. Perhaps people didn't really care so much about coding their infants with this color. And I cannot tell you where this association came from, but I can tell you that it's very prevalent. And nowadays, not only in the Western societies, but also in other places wherever you go, you find this kind of gender coding. And this is also reflected in color preferences, very small girls at the age of two, when their gender identity starts forming. They start liking pink and boys start liking blue. And very interestingly, over the years, already at the age of five, boys,
所以这实际上并不那么真实。也许人们并不太关心用这种颜色来编码他们的婴儿。我无法告诉你这种联系是从哪里来的，但我可以告诉你它非常普遍。如今，不仅在西方社会，而且在其他任何地方，你都会发现这种性别编码。这也反映在颜色偏好上，两岁的小女孩，当她们的性别认同开始形成时。她们开始喜欢粉色，而男孩开始喜欢蓝色。非常有趣的是，多年来，早在五岁时，男孩，
completely avoid pink. So it's really about the pink. It's not about the blue. I just told you that blue is one of the favorite colors of everyone. So it's really about the pink that boys are avoiding pink and girls like both blue and pink. And with time, this kind of gets established also in our language. We recently did a study on Wikipedia articles where we looked at word embeddings and we found that really the word pink occurs so much more often. with feminine words than any other color term, whereas neither blue nor red, nor any other color term was not specifically associated with masculinity. So it's kind of really, you need these two colors together to know which one is for boys and which one is for girls. That raises the question
就完全避开粉色。所以这确实是关于粉色的。这与蓝色无关。我刚才告诉你，蓝色是每个人最喜欢的颜色之一。所以这确实是关于粉色的，男孩们在避开粉色，而女孩们既喜欢蓝色又喜欢粉色。随着时间的推移，这种联系也建立在我们的语言中。我们最近对维基百科文章进行了一项研究，我们查看了词嵌入，发现“粉色”这个词确实比任何其他颜色术语更频繁地与女性词汇一起出现，而蓝色、红色或任何其他颜色术语都没有特别与男性气质联系在一起。所以这确实是，你需要把这两种颜色放在一起才知道哪一种是给男孩的，哪一种是给女孩的。这就提出了一个问题，
of whether colors go in and out of style. Like you could look at a house and pinpoint the decade that it was decorated just from the color scheme. Are these just random fads or, you can Can you learn something from colors that are popular at a particular time? I guess this is a question for an interior or exterior designer. Because I've been talking about this universal associations between colors and demotions, kind of universally found color preferences, and I don't think that they change that much over time. It's really more the availability and,
颜色是否会过时。就像你可以看一栋房子，仅从配色方案就能指出它是哪个年代装饰的。这些只是随机的时尚，还是你可以从特定时间流行的颜色中学到一些东西？我想这是一个给室内或室外设计师的问题。因为我一直在谈论颜色和情绪之间这种普遍的联系，这种普遍发现的颜色偏好，我不认为它们随着时间的推移而改变那么多。这确实更多的是关于可用性和，
Every generation wants to differentiate themselves from a previous generation, and color is one of the ways of doing it. And we see colors coming back over and over again. If we think about this pink in early 2000, it was really the fuchsia, a very bright pink that was popular. And recently it was a very soft shade of pink, baby pink, and then, yeah, there is another term for this very, very soft pink that was popular. with the Barbie movie, perhaps another shade of pink will come up.
每一代人都想把自己与前一代人区分开来，而颜色就是实现这一目标的方法之一。我们看到颜色一次又一次地回归。如果我们想到2000年初的这种粉色，那确实是紫红色，一种非常明亮的粉色，当时很流行。而最近是一种非常柔和的粉色，婴儿粉，然后，是的，还有另一个词来形容这种非常非常柔和的粉色，当时很流行。随着芭比电影的上映，也许会出现另一种粉色。
So we kind of circling, we take the same hue. So here we're talking about what people normally refer to color, but there are also other dimensions that are important, namely lightness and saturation. Colors can be dark or light. They can be very, very bright, very saturated, or they can be very grayish and dull. And this is what designers can do.
所以我们有点在循环，我们采用相同的色调。所以在这里我们谈论的是人们通常所说的颜色，但还有其他重要的维度，即明度和饱和度。颜色可以是深色或浅色。它们可以是极其明亮、极其饱和的，或者它们可以是灰蒙蒙的、暗淡的。这就是设计师可以做的事情。
They can take these dimensions and they can play with them and they can give you an impression that you're seeing new colors over, yeah, new colors from time to time, when in fact they are just manipulating a few dimensions. And I know you've done work regarding color in art, and I'm wondering what have you found regarding the presence of color in art? What is the meaning, how to artists choose color, and why do they choose what they choose? Yes, so this is another line of research that I am currently pursuing, and unfortunately I don't have the data yet. but what I know from others research is that, for example, if you ask people to produce artworks and you ask them to draw anything, but that would represent a specific emotion, let's say anger or disgust,
他们可以利用这些维度，他们可以玩转它们，他们可以给你一种印象，让你觉得你时不时地看到了新的颜色，而事实上他们只是在操纵几个维度。我知道你做过关于艺术中颜色的工作，我想知道你在艺术中颜色的存在方面发现了什么？意义是什么，艺术家如何选择颜色，为什么他们选择他们所选择的？是的，这是我目前正在进行的另一条研究路线，不幸的是我还没有数据。但我从其他研究中知道的是，例如，如果你要求人们创作艺术品，并要求他们画任何东西，但要代表一种特定的情绪，比如愤怒或厌恶，
non-artist participants are using much more common color emotion associations, whereas artists are using much more uncommon colors. So really, artist's mind is much, have many more diverse associations and they might combine colors in a very unusual way to perhaps evoke a certain feeling in the viewers or, yeah, to use
非艺术家参与者会使用更多常见的颜色-情绪联系，而艺术家会使用更多不常见的颜色。所以艺术家的思维确实有更多样化的联系，他们可能会以非常不寻常的方式组合颜色，也许是为了在观众中唤起某种感觉，或者，是的，为了使用
kind of non-traditional colors. So it is very tricky to research color use in art because you don't know if they're using the color as the society would think or if they're using on purpose the opposite color but they still know about the existing associations. But yes, this is an ongoing research, and I hope that in the future I will have more answers.
某种非传统的颜色。所以研究艺术中的颜色使用是非常棘手的，因为你不知道他们是在使用社会所认为的颜色，还是他们故意使用相反的颜色，但他们仍然知道现有的联系。但是是的，这是一项正在进行的研究，我希望在未来我会有更多的答案。
What are the big questions that you still want to answer, and what are you working on right now? So currently, as I told you, I'm working on their research studies with blind people, and I really want to understand to what extent the psychological meaning of color, the link with emotions, the preferences are determined by our society, and to what extent we need to see colors in order to have any of these associations. And I think this preliminary data that I have on blind people is really exciting
你仍然想回答的重大问题是什么，你现在正在研究什么？所以目前，正如我告诉你的，我正在进行关于盲人的研究，我真的很想了解颜色的心理意义、与情绪的联系、偏好在多大程度上是由我们的社会决定的，以及我们需要在多大程度上看到颜色才能拥有这些联系中的任何一种。我认为我拥有的关于盲人的这些初步数据真的非常令人兴奋，
because it shows that color is very, very important to them. For example, they say that when they get dressed, they think that they want to choose colors that are matching. They don't want to appear as a clown, as one of the participants said. So it's really much more high. effort task than it is for a sighted person. They have all different ways of matching their colors. And then they know that certain colors symbolize certain things. They say, I like blue, so I want to wear a blue, and I have to find this blue for myself. So really, this research
因为它表明颜色对他们来说非常非常重要。例如，他们说当他们穿衣服时，他们认为他们想选择搭配的颜色。正如其中一位参与者所说，他们不想看起来像个小丑。所以这确实是一项比视力正常的人付出更多努力的任务。他们有各种不同的搭配颜色的方法。然后他们知道某些颜色象征着某些事物。他们说，我喜欢蓝色，所以我想穿蓝色，我必须为自己找到这种蓝色。所以确实，这项研究
for the blind people is opening a new avenue into the world of language and into the world of our culture. So to wrap up, let me ask you one unscientific question, which is what's your favorite color and why? So actually my favorite color is red, not blue, and I don't have a reason. I think that's how it is with color preferences. Often people just like colors or dislike them, and that's how it is. Yeah. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Yonazkaita. It's been really interesting. Thank you for having me. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
对于盲人来说，正在开辟通往语言世界和我们文化世界的新途径。所以总结一下，让我问你一个非科学的问题，那就是你最喜欢的颜色是什么，为什么？所以实际上我最喜欢的颜色是红色，不是蓝色，我没有理由。我认为颜色偏好就是这样。人们通常只是喜欢或不喜欢某种颜色，事情就是这样。是的。好吧，我要感谢你今天加入我，Yonazkaita博士。这真的很有趣。谢谢你的邀请。这是一种荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。